-Hey, pal.
-Hey.
-So you really think
Brad Pitt and Rihanna,
that would be --
-I feel like -- Come on.
-But you --
-They're so gorgeous.
-But you just saw --
you just saw Brad at --
'Cause I know Kanye had his --
-Sunday Service.
-His -- This service.
-Yeah.
-He does these services
on Sunday,
and Brad Pitt went to it.
-He did. He was there.
He -- I think he's been
a couple times.
But that was the first time that
I was there when he was there.
And I literally left early.
I-I couldn't even -- I just saw
"Once Upon a Time In Hollywood."
And it was so good.
And he just, like,
gets better with age.
So I was like,
"I got to go." Like --
-Why? You didn't
want to meet him?
-No. Because
isn't there a saying,
like, don't ever meet
your superhero or whatever?
I don't know.
I just, like, love him so much.
I'm like, "I'm just going
to leave it at that."
-Wow.
-"And leave."
-No way.
-I get nervous. And I, like --
-Well, I guess
that you would get nervous.
You'd probably be nervous
meeting you. Please.
[ Laughter ]
I have -- I know
NFL just kicked off.
Tonight was the big deal,
and everyone's talking
about football.
And I was looking through
old photos
and information about you.
And I found
that you were a cheerleader.
-Yeah.
-And I didn't know that.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Here's a photo of you.
-No!
-It's so cute. Come on.
That is awesome. Now --
-I was a cheerleader.
-Were you really into it?
-I was into it.
I think I was more into it
'cause there was a really cute
boy on the football team
that I really liked.
-Oh, really?
-So I was like,
"I want to be a cheerleader."
But I ended up making some of --
My two best friends
are from -- are girls
that I met from cheer.
So it all ended up working out,
and I had so much fun.
It was a really cool experience.
But I still --
Like, we took a class
to learn football,
and I still don't --
I can't follow it.
I just don't really know
what's going on.
-You know the rules of --
-No. I'm more of
a basketball girl.
-Yeah, I --
-I like -- I'm a basketball fan.
-I learned how -- 'cause my
parents are both from Brooklyn.
And they know how --
I know the rules of stick ball.
I can do that.
But football is not a thing.
So I learned from
playing video games.
-Shut up. Really?
-"John Madden Football"
taught me how to play --
All the rules of football
I know from that.
But do you remember any cheers?
-Yeah, I could show you one.
But you have to, like,
really do it.
-Oh, I'll do it with you?
-Yeah, come on.
-I mean, I'll do it
if I can do it.
I don't know. I'm very --
-It's not hard.
It's, like, an easy one.
-It's an easy one.
-Okay.
So, it goes, Sierra --
-Okay, what, Sierra?
-Let's hear it.
It's like a deodorant roll.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not how
you put on deodorant.
-Swear to God. Swear to God
this is how they explained it...
-That's not how
you put on deodorant.
-...when I was in high school.
-I'm going to start doing that.
-So, Sierra.
-Sierra.
-Let's hear it.
-Pump up.
-Oh, my gosh.
So, wait, so, it's Sierra --
-So it goes, Sierra,
let's hear it.
-Let's hear it.
-Pump up -- [ Laughs ]
-Pump up.
-That spirit.
-The spirit.
Okay, good. Sierra, let's
hear it. Pump up the spirit.
-Yeah, Sierra, let's hear it.
-Okay, ready?
-Pump up that spirit.
-Alright.
-So, Sierra.
-Oh, sorry, sorry. Sierra.
Let's hear it.
Pump up the spirit!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love it.
-Dude --
-Deodorant roll.
-I love this move.
-Yeah, the deodorant roll.
-This is going to be
my new wedding dance.
I'm going to be like,
"Oh, I love this jam."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're welcome.
-Oh, thank you so much.
Oh, my gosh.
What was -- What was Sierra?
That was the name of the --
-Sierra Can-- I go -- I went to
a school called Sierra Canyon.
-Hey, shout-out to those guys.
-Yeah.